[Musique]
2 ouais ben trop maintenant vous êtes
d'acrobates ah oui un peu oui aouita
grosse averse et à la maison truc
toutefois averti ouais et à l'entente
vous le faites vos miches à 45
ça fait une trentaine à
mais vous l'avez c'est vous qui aviez
commencé ce métier où richard j'ai
commencé par une entreprise chez nos
entreprises maintenant je suis à mon
compte puis
c'est agréable
oui parce que j'ai réussi à acheter un
sac est un atelier à bord pourquoi ben
on est plus libre ouais on est plus
libre de disposer de votre temps quand
vous voulez davantage de conversation
[Musique]
vous composez un tableau
ce sont des pièces uniques comme un
tableau qui ce que vous composez une
seule fois et à chaque fois c'est autre
chose
vous improvisé où vous composez vraiment
sous sur le coup
il ya longtemps que vous tissez monsieur
van tu
je viens de prendre le consommateur de
ce monsieur et je vais mettre ce
consommateur
dans cet appareil pour reconstituer
la présence de têtes et la mesure exacte
avant de commencer la confession du
chapiteau
voilà bernard vous remarquerez que c'est
un bras qui
n'affiche de fabrication bon d'accord
faites attention à l'abattage recense
entre des centres de données
chapeau de paille d'italie ce oui c'est
un japon paille d'italie que je suis en
train de préparer pour un client
et que je suis en train de refaire mais
avec une corde qu'il était trop ouvert
je sais faire avec un conte formateur
aussi à celles qui étaient avec un conte
formateur maintenant elle le chaperon
terminé et j'ai plus qu'à le mettre sur
bris dès qu'on appelle une bride et
après ça fera un planteur superbe
planteurs
on
devient un chat poser c'est de faire
part de faire office manqué une fois il
fallait avoir une famille dont la pierre
sèche et j'ai un petit artisan
connaisseurs ses débuts du talent dans
deux mois je n'ai débuté à 16 ans et
jean les 46 ça fait déjà 30 ans après ça
fait pas mal oui il est tout le monde
peut le faire on va si ça plaît non mais
est-ce qu'on peut entrer comme on veut
dans lara non non non non il fallait
être là à voir un membre de sa famille
qui était chapeau ni malheureusement je
vais pas m'en faire chapelier mais
j'avais un nantais ska a résolu le
problème
c'est à dire que quand j'étais tout
petit j'avais 5 6 ans je voyais déjà
molle ont fabriqué les chats pour lui
d'ici vivant de voir tout ça et quand ma
foi je suis arrivé à 16 ans j'ai dit à
mon père moi je veux faire les chapeaux
et je suis rentré dans la chapellerie
mais grâce à mon nom
annoncé très agréable et les gens
quand ils viennent vous l'achetez sont
rien avant général des gens agréables
que j'ai
[Musique]
oui ou le fait qu'al dimanche seront
cédées pendant nos champs la semaine
aussi le travail que vous avez toujours
des clients comme tout le commerce
c'est quand même agréable à voir c'est
très agréable à faire mais c'est pas la
facilité certainement que vous l'avez
choisi
toi comme ça parce que j'aime la cub
non
le jeu
[Musique]
pensons à notre liberté ça me dire en
l'absence
on a toujours fait ce métier-là des
enfants
et le falher play le travail de leur
père oui le plus vieux ça y intéresse il
faudrait déjà
pourquoi vous avez choisi ce travail au
pass éducation de la liberté puis ça
nous plaît
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
alors
[Musique]
mais souvent ici
je fais tous les quartiers
le genre reconnaissent
dans certains quartiers
vous revenez souvent en même temps moi
oui parce que c'est un problème
également
au niveau
mon niveau foot il ya des quartiers où
les pluies sont très tolérants comme un
mouchoir ou pas c'est interdit ah oui
absolument garder de faire de leur de
leur divulguer de la musique comme ça en
public de 7 h
ben musiques nordestines apparemment les
fruits qui va faire le violon
semblablement alors donc il ya des
quartiers où on va à st à saint germain
est bien
ce père ana c
on y revient quoi parce que les gens
s'attroupent failli pourquoi qui
s'applique pas les gens s'attroupent et
puis je les écoute à nous ils perdent
apparemment il aime ça
et ça aussi pas
ah non vous aimez sert aussi à moi
j'adore faire la ville avait choisi
exprès moi je vis avec l'appui
j'attendais mieux vous l'avez toujours
fait non non
j'étais comme tout le monde
bah je sais pas du tout la machine métro
dodo à peu près à damas et ses environs
malheureusement pas s'esclaffer
villégier
[Musique]
bédié
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les moins sûrs et à tous un gosse
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelquefois on en mettra lui qui va
s'arrêter là
[Musique]
oui aux
enfers
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
bord
nous avons
beaucoup avons vu combien d'ados
très content très content
[Musique]
parce qu'on voit beaucoup de monde
voyez ça va ça vient on a des amis
passent par la tête les clients viennent
c'est bon il ya une transparence on est
loin
[Musique]
faux
m
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur
enfin pour 1 reçoivent la jme fais pour
pouvoir travailler à savez jamais vu des
cours donnés travail énorme et j'aime
beaucoup regarder travailler parce
qu'aujourd'hui on ne fait pas beaucoup
des ouvrages comme dans le temps
n'est ce pas aujourd'hui vraiment ri cho
aimait son métier pour y rester
l ancien métier espère oui
on ne devient pas ce qu'on aime bien son
métier c'est comme ça on devient bon
colonies
beaucoup de temps il faut quand même eu
4 5 en or laitiers pour la prendre et on
meurt on n'apprend pas tout tous les ans
après un petit peu plus
et chaque fois
on fait du beau travail après quand on
apprend bien le métier mais c'est
dommage de ne pas beaucoup des
cordonniers
[Musique]
chomienne douzaine d'huîtres
aura la journée on
353 sans
vouloir
deuxième jambe pour les ouvrir
six personnes
il ya le faire comme s'ils voulaient
rien n'est fait
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ans
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
deux pages aux durs de moitié chez ses
parents non cet acrobate quand même oui
il ya 6 il ya là il faut point long
apprentissage pour la cinquante six bons
mois pour le faire si bon ça fait
combien de temps comme ils prêts
ça fera 21 ans le
l'expérience pourquoi vous l'avez oublié
parce que on est indépendants ont
seulement sur yable séquence quand on
voit la main il ya pas des gens qui vous
demandent comment on devient colleurs
d'affichés y en a qui nous entamons la
valeur d'affiché comme les petits gosses
franklin roosvelt y en a qui m'avait dit
que je ferais comme mois plus tard il
est revenu à marquer c'est n'importe
quoi il nous a pas demandé je commence
de bonne heure le matin vers 6h ils vous
pouvez commencer à 9 heures jusqu'à neuf
heures du soir une balle pendant il faut
aller vite quand même il fallait
[Musique]
je
[Applaudissements]
bon
on
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]